now that robert downey jr has officially
moved on from his role as iron man can
you guess what project the beloved actor
is taking on
two words sweet tooth thanks to rdj
and his wife susan downey's roles as
executive producers
sweet tooth takes viewers on a journey
through some pretty magical plot lines
from cgi to practical effects to
costuming and more
let's take a look at all the factors
that make sweet tooth as fantastical as
it is
if you haven't already heard about all
the buzz surrounding sweet tooth we're
here to fill you in on exactly why this
show is blowing up
the premise of the series is that a
global pandemic hit the world and
resulted in hybrids which are a cross
between human and animal
gus the main character of the series is
one of these hybrids a cross between
deer and human
i never saw a deer kid sweet tooth as a
series tells the story of gus
as he travels from the safety of his
home to the catastrophe ridden outside
world
people out there hunt kids like you
don't make it easy for them
as we all know cgi dominates most of the
special effects
that we see on television today it's no
surprise that sweet tooth uses some cgi
in its special effects
but it's a huge surprise that the
majority of the effects seen
in this new series are actually what we
call practical effects
this means that the effects are not
computer generated and are
instead happening in real time why do
you have shiny boxes
never seen a computer sweet tooth
notably uses puppetry in its most
notable effect which is the manipulation
of gus's antlers throughout the show
the ears were totally controlled by
puppeteer grant lehmann
who had to track actor christian
convery's every facial expression
and movement in order to manipulate them
lehman couldn't just watch converi on
screen while controlling his movements
because of a 300 millisecond delay
meaning the puppeteer had to physically
follow around the young actor
this intense process definitely paid off
as gus's character really came to life
with the movement of his antlers and
ears
someone thinks i'm a hybrid i start
talking i never ever move my ears
how does this mechanism work you might
ask
jim mikkel one of the show's creators
commented so christian converi
basically has a little helmet which is
hair and it sits on top
the antlers click in they're amazing
they're really light they click in with
magnets
then he's got these ears that will sit
over the top of his ears
and little cables that run down his back
and he has these little motors that are
strapped to his back the whole time that
are hidden
then there's a puppeteer that operates
on him remotely they can do
all sorts of shapes and reactions and
speeds sounds complicated to me but it
turned out to be so
so worth it there are no kids like me
the only one left
that's what he told you gus was not the
only hybrid brought to life through
puppetry in this series
in fact puppetry played a pretty
significant role in bringing the idea of
hybrids to life overall
interestingly enough all of the baby
hybrids featured in episode 1
were real puppets even more impressively
the character bobby was a real-life
puppet who was controlled through
multiple talented puppeteers and a
harness system
talk about some intense teamwork the
rest of the children within the series
who were also cast as hybrids were
brought to life using intense makeup
prosthetics which highlighted very
specific
animalistic features for each of the
young actors
last dijk you were part animal too you
know
makeup artist stefan knight and his team
were able to bring these half human
creatures to life using this method
everyone knows that the casting process
in hollywood can be pretty cutthroat
for actor christian convery who plays
gus the audition process seemed to run
pretty smoothly as the young actor made
it through callbacks and landed the role
with little stress
he's bigger than you it'll make him
bigger than me
actor nonso anazi had a bit of a harder
time
in the casting process though claiming
he had to fight a bit more for the role
as many people loved the role of tommy
shepard and also wanted a shot at
playing him
they bought what i was telling him and
here i am playing tommy jennifer today
the young actor immediately began
studying the mannerisms of deer once he
landed the part in order to best prepare
for the role
researched how years move and react this
level of acting for such a young actor
is super impressive and really
noteworthy converi
is only 11 years old not only did the
child star work to perfect his
animal-like acting performance
but he also took parkour lessons to best
learn safe ways to move about like an
animal too
because deers have to run and jump
really fast all the time
this level of dedication to the acting
game is seriously
something magical if you ask me anozie
didn't have to take part in
any parkour training but had to take
fight lessons instead
as his big fight scene of the first
episode required him to have some
professional training
so that was that was pretty tough now
you might be asking yourself how did the
production team go about handling the
fact that this series is set in the
midst of a pandemic
did they take notes from the covet
outbreak that's sweeping the globe to
get their pandemic information down pat
the answer is surprisingly no the pilot
of this series was
filmed in may and june of 2019 before
the pandemic truly took a foothold
globally
before the greek crumble so what did the
production team do
to make their fictional pandemic as
accurate as they could
instead the team studied previous
outbreaks of the bird flu and sars to
get their information as close to
reality as possible
all of our science tracked when the real
pandemic started said jim mikel
one of the show's creators and
showrunners not only was the way in
which the team tackled the portrayal of
the pandemic really fantastic
but so was their fortunate decision to
shoot on location in new zealand
new zealand is a country known for its
intense and startling natural beauty
pretty much making the use of cgi or any
other digital enhancements pointless
valley of sorrows it looks pretty happy
to me
not only did this make new zealand the
perfect setting for the fantastical
series
but the way the nation was affected by
kovid also helped with little
to no shutdown the production process
that took place in 2020 was able to keep
on rolling
as anazi stated when we found out that
new zealand was one of the countries
that had got their act together the
quickest and we'd be able to shoot there
that was a very great thing from amazing
casting efforts to great scientific
research and even lucky location
scouting
it seems that the production process
behind the scenes of sweet tooth was
truly impressive which can be clearly
seen in the final product of the series
as you probably already know the team
behind the scenes of sweet tooth was
also a major reason for the series
newfound success
with robert downey jr and his wife susan
downey at the helm of the production
team
there was really no doubt that this
series was gonna be a hit
we'd like a challenge and an adventure
in this was both
the couple decided to create a much more
family-friendly version of this original
graphic novel leaving out a bit of the
gritty darkness of the series in place
of some hope
as susan downey stated the ambition was
to create it for a family audience
we wanted the whole family to be able to
watch together
rdj went on to say that the comics had
this scope and emotional breadth of
storytelling
and the characters were just so engaging
we wanted to make a great co-viewing
experience for parents and kids
just think think of the possibility sure
enough the power couple
definitely met their goal now there's no
way to talk about sweet tooth and its
adaptation into a television series
without acknowledging what the original
author has to say about it
thankfully author of the sweet tooth
graphic novel series jeff lemire has
nothing bad to say in fact when asked
about what it was like to see his comic
come to life the author said
it's pretty magical it was really
interesting to see which aspects of the
world
jim and the team latched onto and how
they leaned into the hopefulness of the
story and gus's innocence
and kind of bringing something new to it
um it's been interesting
as we can see from our behind-the-scenes
look at sweet tooth
it was really a bunch of different
factors that led the series to be the
greatness that it is
from casting choices to puppetry and
prosthetics the impressiveness of the
production process is clear
everywhere next time you're watching
sweet tooth keep all this
exclusive information in mind it will
make you appreciate the series
even more